the jurogan experience i love a good
superhero movie i'm corny
you like like avengers and [ __ ] like you
like aquaman i like it when they bring
in the hulk
yeah i like the hulk
i didn't watch aquaman because i'm not
i'm not watching any movie with amber
heard in it
i'll tell you what i am watching is the
trial i do it's the best reality show of
all time i think i need to spark a joint
up if we're going to talk about the
truck do it bro because i can't get
enough of it it's literally it's amazing
it's fantastic it's the best thing on tv
at first i was upset because you know i
watched the news and they interrupted
ukraine getting bombed in the middle of
a war with russia it's like breaking
news johnny depp amber heard i'm like oh
god what are we doing here i was like
let's see what's happening i was like oh
hell yes
it's like sign me up dude it's it's it's
a cautionary tale for people that were
thinking that it's worth it to date a
crazy girl because she's great in bed
no this is my thing though how great is
she in bed that she can [ __ ]
in your bed she can rip your [ __ ]
index finger off and
she must she must be a real tomcat in
the sack dude i think he's probably a
really nice guy and he
had great moments with her and he keeps
going back to those great moments
and thinking they can get past all this
craziness
because johnny i don't know johnny well
i've talked to him before
but i know
of his career and i know of his love of
hunter thompson and he's close with uh
uh dan stanhope yeah very close that's
how i know him that's how i've met him
while i've talked to him i met him once
personally in a comedy story but i
talked him on the phone for an extended
period of time once when he was dealing
with all this [ __ ] and
i think he's a really good guy that's
what i think i think he's he likes chaos
though he likes doing cocaine
he probably likes doing things he
shouldn't do like he probably likes
driving fast he's probably an animal in
in some ways like he just loves like
chaos and i think that's one of the the
reasons why he loved hunter thompson he
loved a brilliant man who loved chaos
and that's what hunter was hunter was
just like
brilliant writer
who was a culture
cultural commentator
who also
enjoyed getting like obliterated
how long were we talking well hunter
killed himself in the early 2000s okay
um after what was it like 2010
11 or something like that
i forget what year killed himself okay
but johnny was friends with him yeah and
johnny played him in the movie um uh you
know fear and loathing in las vegas
and uh he also yeah he also narrated the
hunter thompson documentary which is um
uh
was it gonzo life and
yeah that just five what's that
um
colorado probably died yeah yeah he shot
himself i mean he was hurting at the end
he had hip replacements and he was
constant pain
and
a life of doing drugs
like hardcore drugs and uh alcohol
obliterated his body so that was
johnny's uh johnny depp's north star
basically yeah that's his that's his
hero in a lot of ways i mean johnny depp
is i i'm
i i i don't know the exact details but
he has a significant amount of hunter
thompson memorabilia like he bought a
significant amount yeah when the wife
when hunter's wife was going to get rid
of some stuff johnny stepped in and got
it all johnny
johnny paid for hunter's funeral oh wow
it was millions of dollars he built a
cannon to shoot hunter's ashes
into the sky and like you know that that
he has this um
this uh logo that's uh i don't know if
you've seen that hunter thompson for
sheriff poster that i have out there
he has a logo that's a fist with two
thumbs like a mutant fist that has a
masculine tab in the center of it and
that's his logo
and so he made a giant cannon
out of this logo
and
you play this because this is hunter
talking about it
they'll do it from the beginning because
he's explaining to the
the mortuary how he wants this done
it's hilarious
yeah so he just decided that he was
going to do this and johnny depp
actually wound up doing it
at his at his funeral
well i mean clearly he was going to blow
his head off though i mean yeah so this
is him to do particularly with me
this is a this is a young hunter
planning this out
god that is dark yeah and so when he got
old and you know became friends with
johnny i mean johnny's got
all the [ __ ] cash in the world so he
decided to just do it and so he spent
millions of dollars building this
[ __ ] cannon and shooting hunter's
ashes into the sky that jack sparrow
mother
i think what [ __ ] him up too that's
that's the the rocket jesus christ
this is crazy that he actually went so
dark
i mean music's all fun johnny depp is
hilarious that he fact just the fact
that he did that he carried through i
agree he's a legend spent millions on it
i'm a fan man but also
think how long johnny's been famous too
so he's gonna be wired a little
different you know what i'm saying yeah
it's not good it's like
the way i've described it is like
getting famous when you're really young
and trying to be a fully grown adult is
like
making cement but you don't use all the
material and it doesn't cure right you
don't you don't grow up in a realistic
world no it's nothing's real yeah it's
beyond that's ralph stedman the guy
who's drawing it who did all the hunter
s thompson artwork he's a brilliant
artist and so
he helped hunter design it i don't know
if he was
but look at this
this is the [ __ ] cannon
[Music]
i'm on team depp for life you hear me
yeah me too team depp yeah man i mean i
wish you wouldn't wear uh eyeliner but
yeah yeah and a little too many scarves
right right yeah he i don't give a [ __ ]
here's my thing without giving a [ __ ]
anymore
i don't he can do no wrong in my book
i'm a johnny dup fan if i was younger i
probably criticize him for it now i'm
like yeah wait look at that there it is
this is super dark it's a wild move man
the guy shoots his [ __ ] ashes into
the sky out of a goddamn cannon it's a
touch it's a glowing fist it's a tough
follow yeah how are you gonna die and
all these people go to
his [ __ ] funeral bill murray who also
played him in where the buffalo roam
which is another fun hunter thompson
movie but the guy was a writer yeah and
two different
big time movie stars played him
johnny depp and [ __ ] and yeah bill
murray bill murray that's that's what a
bad [ __ ] hunter thompson bill
murray has some anger issues huh i don't
know allegedly maybe someone was a [ __ ]
on the set i agree maybe they deserved
it i'd like to hear both sides of the
story
yeah man there's people watching it from
a distance yeah my funeral will not be
like that yeah don't waste that money on
me man i'm out